ergo your pay
[Music]
oh this is lando yeah trying to put this
on land Oh fewer channels so a land
Ocala 15 land Oh Calvin
try to look me up on YouTube I mean I'm
nobody special
I'm nothing interesting also hey you
never know I haven't I didn't know you
had a channel I just opened it up
[Music]
yeah all right I heard the wind on their
working work I know everything
and so you're playing katana right
cultural appropriation
[Applause]
eat your her garlic Joanne Oh Joe I gave
you some crap and I need you apologize
effective immediately
Tamara apology oh that's the whole video
series nothing and here we have viola
you're too good for this movie I don't
care why you're my way you know I think
not pretend I could do this all done
okay all right like what are you ready I
think not because then it turns out I
can do this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I would actually Walter when you did the
shot your arm kind of fell off camera
those right on
oh my go yeah oh that's why we're gonna
schedule a bigger job
okay okay I'll go little more of that
sure he is out of this as much as
possible Wolfie you can come back more
ten and not to my knees like maybe 500
you get I'm sorry okay I'm perfectly
okay concern about that right how about
this Phuket course okay eight years oh
you're all completely up okay all right
now so now it's going to go through me
Taylor the rods and Roger used up as a
sign of that and even won't be like a
you know like the Apple there's
consoling you okay you ready and
okay jumping tease again everyone go
individually and get me to come so
everyone a lot of the time so Malcolm go
all the way via then I can kill you
actually once you're at it frame out
okay that's that's cool we can do that
alright and yeah just just go ahead and
say it because I can see
okay good good alright we all agree
Malcolm to stay a step back hey Gazoo
all right ready all right and action
small tea
[Applause]
Yahoo hey I quit this is a culturally
appropriate action I can sit down as
long yeah I know it's tough man actually
let's give you a safety from the thing
all the way up and I roll I'm using this
run for me is gonna be crap today
yes my say anything
[Applause]
[Music]
you look like the better right online
very good I gotta tell you this all in
your head you need to do is hell yeah -
you shot me it picks up your nose oh
then meet it when we do a due to
reaction one more that you did if I just
rang it all gonna frame - it's bad
yeah you can look about there yeah I
like your image
okay first okay I'm done good okay hold
it there okay and oh you know what - any
idea - really good ah okay so heal and
and it's all good for you see that job
oh cool hopeful so F well let's use the
shall we
so for this one you're just going to
save their shot - yeah you don't quite
you don't isn't good enough it's over -
cool it's dead shot good I think I can
get your head shot okay it's over ten
full dead shot look good morning
it's art it'll get shot prick go ahead
on the table startled together another
hole I'm going do it again oh that's
really interesting really so Robin I
like it kind of it's very nice no on it
honestly it's working too well like this
is a character and this is just supposed
to be suit number 30 you're probably no
really it really is
yeah we castle remember that because
that's a great that's something I think
but yes this needs to be just a boring
you don't like a 90s dj''q her like I'm
give you yeah Noel a melon pool not
saying this is it I'm just this is yes
it is a character it's a definite
character thank you bad yeah something
that we can throw at you a glasses we
call that one April O'Neil I'd like you
to watch your brave Romeo oh it's got
that that book that's good pretty good
look aside on and we get so I can turn
off blood no we have a news trying to
set up the restaurant we need to lights
off
oh yeah that's true so what kind of
restaurant is this yeah with written
record probably yeah I guess I'm good to
tell you or maybe French bistro hmm I'll
go with Italian because that sounds
tasty
Oh Oh No just to give the illusion that
there's something in the background in
here yeah the beaches it's a good idea
good stuff you'll see already ole intro
- yeah ah this thing never learn oh oh
how do you usually wind it I think it's
a lint brush I'm not sure right
wittingly on me yeah oh it's for that
purpose oh I don't know I'm Jessica but
we need that look more dabble stuff
right yeah about like it you you do have
a while could with the way that i am i
yeah i get here itself around actor's
job is never done
no no I don't want your thanks all right
Jim head away wipe off your day is like
a shroud of turin
the Joker makeup for you to come all
right yeah burning up yeah always you're
very viola
yeah doesn't a watch I gave her look at
that yeah okay they man the character
they're talking to me as a character I'm
on violin age I'm just not cello they
make sure when you write that's not
running down your face yeah do that I
hate this sensation Hodges feel like I'm
crying wait really hard okay wrong yeah
and I'm feeling into a few bad guys
because with that they're easily lidded
it's about that come on they were drawn
need hanging out soon also wouldn't to
be hanging out you can only man don't we
have a new surrounding us what you meant
you're on fire Wow from the ladder it's
gonna be tricky
what if I oh right there I just didn't
manage into you Oakland for nooses
[Music]
Canada is EP the cardboard minute hey
yeah you're the cardboard man no no
Wow yeah oh you keep it rolling Ichiro
okay okay what sister you from you
already
my glands sit and tell me those guys as
long as we have that Lynch under control
yeah what are you ever on a lockdown or
military surveillance better we have one
guy looking after her in action yeah
clearly
nah nah what hey no okay I'll call him
right now
[Laughter]
yeah everything philosophy be going oh
let me know how that turns out
so if here she has escaped who would
have known that person bent on ruling
the world will try and rule the world
[Laughter]
little bit from is only thing I notice
sure it came up as she it sounds that I
can achieve you making shit yeah sure
yeah wow that is terrifying got a lot of
rations I'm okay holy shit I need to
play that back for you alright so just a
make sure here's you're gonna be look at
this way this time okay wait let me do
it
yes yeah okay tend to be will record
this well I'd like radio yeah okay
ready and actually coop ah
that time you got here great block and I
will show you this yeah
hey you don't have many lines there's no
specific how I don't know I'm gonna say
yeah yeah just uh you were right
you manage it bitch out there is some
sort of team right yeah you just sort
but you have your own folder like you
kinda know here just yeah maybe what
cost at that five I'm a super team out
of your name that you gave it right yeah
and political say more like moment ok
Suisse wide Suicide Squad wait a minute
that can't be you can't because this and
I'll go on and on and on and I'll just
get your you just kinda like yeah and
let me see I don't think I don't think
you put your hand where I look that I'm
seeing is like this is me like just
where I'm gonna be
I'm sorry no smell really bad you see
like it I don't think oh yeah okay yeah
Becca I'll get the focus
I also chair your sideline good okay
drought putting a movie night ready and
action
where are you yellow finger get over
here oh my god that looks really good
that's the one yeah yeah that was really
good actually
good swing and good reaction yeah we
yeah I'm not gonna lie I heard like a
couple of quick but no good I heard oh I
can't close to the band bag okay y'all
ready yeah ready an act oh my god Robert
Bryce Rob Rob sit out if you guys
happens off your rap you can see Robin
story where he looks at waiting out a
little off everybody yeah okay that's
good okay we'll try another one okay
y'all ready and actually y'all better
there's no Jo happy don't hate let's
just
[Applause]
okay okay okay good only it'll get so
dirty issue
no I'm interest how's it like it really
look right combat-trained yeah no let me
yeah you're done with it yeah
you have three combat people and
one-third here's been talking about that
for years of you has me never from
memory
oh I mean someone really yeah and say oh
it's over will be the summer okay so I'm
gonna have a bum Jim's gonna be there as
Joe crank just go ah you know like give
me a hug you come in like give them a
good guess it doesn't matter to make up
smooth like a thing whenever they go PSA
we're yeah I'm already everywhere yeah
so
give a great big hello again you just go
ah yeah up in the air and you can do
this for a good like maybe 10 15 seconds
just like multi laughing ha ha
and then I'll say boom and it turns out
you're shooting like hit the copying up
oh my gosh and I think this was a path
through life yeah but what my bad
they're like a big fault and I suppose
yeah yeah and you can cry out to her do
you have these like this now we can just
cut the remember me yes my prior job
okay well what am I gonna decorate ready
I am ready okay so we can just we can
just have the script like right here the
more thing about Oh we'll get along yeah
do bill in there okay oh I'll leave it
rolling
yeah just leave it real that's what will
would do don't you so say that you're
gonna go so that they acting just
[Applause]
[Music]
okay are you doing yeah we should
okay this is to tell me because we might
make this the bill dance tell me all
about those the origins the building
yeah okay because you guys are just
doing this and I just thought I'm like
is that actually a dance they said no
and I said I think we have to make this
the bill dance cuz specially with the
boxing glove it looks so great
so yes this is the birth of the bill
dance
it's just our rebirth actually came up
with it a few minutes ago but still okay
[Music]
you